لحتى تعرف مين اللاعب الاكثر اكتمالا
بالعالم او المهاجم الاكثر اكتمالا
بالعالم لازم تتابع المنتخب الفرنسي ولازم
تطلع على الجهه اليسرى للمنتخب الفرنسي
اللي فيها كيليان مبابي مبابي هو اللاعب
الاكثر اكتمالا حاليا في العالم اللي
بيعملوا بابي مش سهل مشي عادي ولو انه
يبدو انه هو شيء بسيط او شيء سهل ولكن
قدرات امبابه والطرق التي يسجل منها
الاهداف براي شخص وهو بعرف هذا الشيء ممكن
يعرضني الانتقادات ولكن برايي الشخصي انه
هو دمج ما بين ميسي وكريستيانو رونالدو مع
بعض
اولا وقبل ما تبلش تهاجم اسمع منيح هل
ميسي قادر على تسجيل اهداف بالراس
بالطريقه الي بيسجل فيها كليان مبابي لا
اعتقد ذلك طيب هل رونالدو قادر على مراوغه
لاعب واثنين وثلاثه وقادر انه يتفوق
بسباقات بسرعه على لاعبين سريعين جدا على
الاطراف بالوقت الحالي او حتى لما كان
بفترته مع ريال مدريد ربما ولكن هل هو
بسرعه كيليان مبابي اعتقد لا قدره الباطل
ما بتختصر بس على السرعه والتسجيل بالراس
وما الى ذلك بيسجل بكل الطرق الممكن بسجل
بقدمه اليمنى بقدمه اليسرى بالراس بالفخذ
الايمن مثل ما شفنا جوله على الدنمارك
بسجل بكل الطرق الممكنه مش بس هيك لا
بيصنع اهداف واهداف حازم جدا مبابي اذا
انت واياه بالواحد على واحد او عليه مدافع
واحد فقط اعتبر المدافع الله يرحمه لذلك
باقي لاعب عادي مبابي ما يقدمه في كاس
العالم الحالي وقدرات الفنيه الفرديه مش
قدرات طبيعيه مش قدرات لاعب عادي امبارح
بهدفه امام المنتخب البولندي استلم كوره
على حدود المنطقه او داخل المنطقه كان بس
بعد الخط بشوي عليه مدافعين اي لاعب ثاني
كان راح يفكر اما انه ياخذ الكره بلمسه
زائد على الجهه اليمنى و يلعبها بالزاويه
البعيده او انه يفكر يراوغ او يقص باتجاه
الجهه اليسرى ويلعب كره ارضيه باليسار او
انه يفكر بنفس الطريقه ولكن بدل ما يلعب
العرضيه يلعب الكره بالزاويه اللي بعيده
اليسرى ولكن مبابي كان عنده راي اخر
استلام الكره اول لمسه ثاني لمسه الكره
بالمقصه الايمن لحارس المرمى مش الايسر مش
الزاويه اللي بعيده بالمقص الايمن لمين
تشيزني
وهاي بالمناسبه واحده من اكثر الكرات اللي
بتروح راس المرمى لانه حارس المرمى لما
تعطيه كره عاليه وبالزاويه انتهى الامر
خلص الموضوع ما بالك اذا كانت هاي الكره
على زاويته
وقوه امبابه انه بيعطي الحارس شيء مش
متوقع يعني الكره لما بتيجي بهذا الشكل
لما بياخذ هذا القرار بالتسديد بهذا
الزاويه هذا امر الحارس مش متوقع وبالتالي
من المستحيل عليه انه يصد الكره
وهاي الحركه رغم انها تبدو سهل وبسيطه
ولكن هي صعبه جدا تحتاج الى توجيه بالقدم
ليمنى بشكل مطلوب تحتاج الى اتخاذ قرار
شجاع بوقت حساس جدا من عمر المباراه
وتحتاج الى لمسه فنيه والى مهاره عاليه من
المهاجم لحتى يسجلها بالمرمى امبارح
الباطن احنا كنا بالملعب وشايفين مباراه
بولندا وفرنسا وكان بيلعب على جهتهماته
كاش كيليان مبابي حرفيا عم بيلعب مع واحد
من اسرع مدافعين الدوري الانجليزي او اسرع
على الاظهره في الدوري الانجليزي والمنتخب
بولندا حاطه الظهير وينج باك وحاطط وراه
مدافع رائد سنتر باك
في لقطه من اللقطات اشتهرت وانتشرت كثير
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ولكن نحن
شفناها بالعين المجرده ماتيكاش باخذ
خطوتين او ثلاث خطوات زياده على امبابه
والكره امامهم وبسباق سرعه بين كاش وبين
امبابه مبابي لحق كاش وسبق كاش واخذ الكره
وتجاوزه هذا امر غير عادي هاي سرعه غير
عاديه مبابي بكاس العالم الحالي شفناه
متنوع بكل شيء شفناه بيلعب كا مهاجم رقم
تسعه بيدخل بيسجل بالراس شفنا عم بيصنع
اهداف عم يلعب دور صالح الالعاب
على واحد وبسمع خطوره على فريقه لمنتخب
بلاده وشفناه قال همم الجناح الانفرتر
اللي بيفوت لجوه منطقه جزاء وبيسجل
الاهداف مبابي قوته ايضا انه خلال ثانيه
ونصف قادر يعمل اربع لمسات للكره
اربع لمسات للكره خلال ثانيه ونصف وفقا
لاحد المحللين بصحيفه اتلتيك يعني هذا امر
غير طبيعي ثانيه ونصف
بيسكن الكره او بيستلمها بالكنترول بياخذ
خطوه للامام بالكره بوضع
الصحيح للتسجيل وبسدد الكره في المرمى كل
هذا الكلام بثانيه ونصف هذا امر غير عادي
هذا امر غير طبيعي
هو امر يعني يفوق الوصف بصراحه هل راح
يقدر كيليان مبابي انه يكون الهداف
التاريخي لكاس العالم الظل على هذا
المستوى بلا شك بلا شك احنا عم نحكي عن
اربع عن اربع مباريات في كاس عالم الحالي
بيسجل فيها خمسه اهداف فرنسا كلها مسجله
ثمانيه اهداف في هذه البطوله كيليان مبابي
خمسه
ليان مبابي اذا استمر على هذا الاداء راح
يتجاوز 16 هدف تبع كروزر وراح يكون قادر
ان يكون هداف التاريخي لا بل انه راح يحطم
الارقام القياسيه يمكن اكثر ما يظلم عليك
كيليان مبابي عالميه انه بيلعب بالدوره
الفرنسي ولكن هذا اللاعب اذا الموسم
القادم بيكون بالدوري الانجليزي او
بالدوري الاسباني راح نشوف كلام ثاني
تماما راح نشوف مبابي بمكان اخر لا يقارن
مع اي لاعب اخر حتى مع حالا لانه مكتمل
اكثر من هدف لذلك لا منقول من هو المهاجم
الاكثر اكتمالا بالعالم لا يمكن ان نبعد
عن كل يعني